war  war never changes  in the year 1945 my  great-great-grandfather  serving in the army  wondered when he'd get to go home to his  wife and the son he'd never seen he got  his wish when the u.s. ended world war 2  by dropping atomic bombs on Hiroshima  and Nagasaki the world awaited  Armageddon instead something miraculous  happened he began to use atomic energy  not as a weapon but as a nearly  limitless source of power people enjoyed  luxuries once thought the realm of  science fiction domestic robots fusion  powered cars portable computers but then  in the 21st century people awoke from  the American dream years of consumption  led to shortages of every major resource  the entire world unravel  peace became a distant memory  it is now a year 2077  we stand on the brink of total war  and I am afraid  for myself for my wife  for my infant son  because of my time in the Army taught me  one thing  instead war war never changes  you